talking of enormous achievements black
panther how nuts is that Martin Freeman
yes Titanic now I don't I'm not sure but
it's um it's done amazingly well and
we're all very proud of it yeah I beg
you are yeah because it's it's it's sort
of taken on this extraordinary life
beyond it's kind of gone but yet it
feels like a moment yeah it's lovely to
be part of that yeah cuz I heard you
talking about you went to the premiere
so they were kind of unlike anything
you'd ever experienced where they were
like football matches yeah they're like
it was they were properly vocal pretty
much every fifth line was getting a big
woofer I mean I think people were hungry
for it you know people wanted it like it
was not just yeah it was it was a bit
more than a film I mean at the end yeah
I'm a big believer in it still has to be
a good film because if it's if it's just
an important thing yeah it's not a good
film then who cares but it has to be a
good film and Ryan Coogler is a clever
chap and when you look at the poster
yourself and Andy Serkis do slightly
stand out yeah the cast had a name for
the two of you yeah we were not because
we had we're performing The Hobbit
together before so we were known as the
Tolkien white guys
[Applause]
[Music]
you